livraison de colis à laval les
propriétaires ne sont pas à la maison on
peut laisser mais il faut qu'on appelle
le clea si ils veulent eux s'ils veulent
par la chance parce qu'amazon nous a dit
on peut prendre une photo et on peut
laisser certains mais il fautr sécurité
il règle de livraison diffèrent selon
les entreprises
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de signatures
requises certaines laissent les colis
sur le pas de la porte ou à l'intérieur
des immeubles à condos le plus possible
à l'abri des regards
si le lieu n'est pas considérée comme
sécuritaires le livreur pourrait essayer
à un autre moment où aller le porter à
huit dépôts s'il les rapporte il ya des
risques jarry peu quelqu'un d'autre les
princesses rémy qui laisse un truc est
pour qu'on ait le prendre à la poste
mais quand c'est des gros colis de foire
si ce plan barre à ses employés estiment
qu'une minorité des expéditeurs exige
une signature je dirais peut-être 10% 5
à 10%
est ce que vous êtes conscient qu'il ya
des risques quand même que les colis ça
ce gaulliste mais c'est très rare
d'autres entreprises demandent que le
propriétaire soit à la maison de la
marchandise qu'on transporte peut être
très très dispendieuse donc c'est
important que
la personne signe pour qu'on ait une
preuve et nos clients payent pour ce
service l'oeuvre aux etats-unis 26
millions de ménages affirment avoir été
victimes de vols de colis si bien que
pour régler le problème des résidents
installe des caméras ou ont même
fabriqué des colis piégés au canada en
fait c'est pas encore un problème qui
généralise et autant que ça peut l'être
aux états unis actuellement les
commerçants vont un avantage étudie la
livraison de colis standard pour une
raison de coût généralement les
marchands vont prendre la responsabilité
si un problème
plusieurs dizaines de millions de colis
sont livrés durant les fêtes au canada
les entreprises de livraison affirme
qu'une minorité seulement ne se rendront
pas destination pour s'assurer que votre
colis se retrouvent entre bonnes mains
mieux vaut évaluer les options livraison
et exiger une signature et c'est marie
laurence de l'aîné radio canada montréal